i just ate something very spicy
hello my name is markiplier and welcome
back to sucker for love chapter one is
done sorry latan
[Music]
[Music]
it's time for chapter two fine i don't
have the secrets yet that's terrifying
but this one looks nice which probably
means that it's absolutely
not nice chapter two the king and yellow
approaches
chapter two
the king in yellow approaches that's
what i said but okay i wonder who i get
to meet this time
not that i think about it wasn't that
other girl was she dressed in yellow oh
god
in a world terrorized by slavery shadows
and tentacled nightmares
something as innocuous as an additional
star in the night sky might be the most
prophetic premonition of doom why is the
screen cut off down there
for rare
for where with hall
am i okay for wherever the lurid golden
light of the planet carcosa shines
the long wicked shadow of the king in
yellow is cast
behind that mask lie echoes of decadence
and disorder masquerades of limitless
cruelty and hideous laughter in equal
part and of all the poor devils seduced
by the lavish promises of the god-king's
court the favored victims of the king's
sadistic amusement
are followers belonging to other
deities
did i zone out i was what was it i don't
remember the sun being that big or the
moon being that big damn i'm having one
hell of a brain fart i can't remember
for the life of me what i'm supposed to
be doing everything feels so hazy was
that going to work
i am standing outside after all
yeah that's gotta be it the sun is
setting so it's probably around 7 pm
which means i'm gonna be crazy late
fantastic also sun real big that's the
beauty of working nights i can't use the
excuse that i ever slept yeah boss i
slept all day saw it up to sundown
that's why i'm
six hours early for my shift huh i'll
sound like the church's noontime bells
it's high noon
no way they must be doing some special
evening service or something i can
clearly see that it's golden hour right
before sunset
i'll just have to ask someone for the
time on my way to work if it's not too
late and i really hope it i'll just get
you down instead of fired
i'll still have to deal with being
sweaty but i'll figure that out when i
get there
oh
someone's coming home perfect fingers
crossed that i'm not absolutely screwed
is that blood hey man sorry to bother
you you wouldn't happen to have the time
on you would you also was that blood is
that blood hello hey uh hey
is this guy ignoring me
did you just move normally i'd say
whatever and walk away but he's
unfortunately standing in the only
stairway off this floor
the only way to exit this conversation
is to shove past him but this guy's
giving me such weird vibes i don't want
to go anywhere near him
the longer i look at him this guy seems
more and more suspicious
that odd posture
he's slowly swaying in an uncanny
disturbing way is he
is he moving
[Music]
i literally
i legitimately can't i he is he
are you moving whatever the collar of
his shirt looks filthy stained with
splotches of deep browns and reds is he
bleeding
does he even live here this is the top
floor and i thought i've met all my
neighbors there are only four apartments
up here my only choices are to go inside
and call the police or to walk past this
freaky guy i don't have the time to wait
around for when the cops show up so i'll
but just as i take a step i kick
something weighty with my shoe it's
bright pink with gold accents
a book what
but i died the world ended oh the shock
freezes me in place and because i was so
distracted i didn't even notice the
[Music]
i'll talk inside my room slamming the
door in the suspicious man's face
fumbling with the locks in a panic i
managed to turn the dead bull
i take a few fearful steps back into the
room clutching the book to my beating
chest i died i definitely died when i
performed the final ritual so why am i
still here where even is here
locked in my room i have nowhere to run
lanetta
lanada
if lynetta was here she could explain
this
maybe there's something in this book
that can save me i need to hurry come on
come on lynette where are you
oh who is this
lynetta you're trying to call
it is you
missy what are you doing tomorrow i knew
you had yellow it's all coming together
i just so happened to overhear you
saying lana where are you
you sounded like you were in trouble so
i let myself in yeah well i was just at
the front door and i just deadbolded it
and i said lynetta after that so that's
weird how did you even get in here your
window was open oh of course
no it's not and either way i'm on the
top floor so how did you panetta sounds
like a girl's name right this is
obviously the girl you stood me up for
isn't she well you're not saying the
name properly you don't have an eldritch
horror mouth in the palm of your hand so
you can't really speak it can you you
wouldn't understand what is there a deal
i knew she'd be pissed i slammed that
door in her face but not so much that
she wouldn't notice any of the things
obviously wrong here
why doesn't she care about those freaky
things stalking me outside or that my
room is full of evil idols and
ritualistic tokens
uh i can explain
hosts a cursive device is used to
channel eldritch magics and do the
bidding of outer gods
[Music]
so many words uh exactly right did you
just randomly guess that i've just been
playing boy
i know exactly what you've been doing oh
okay all right you know what this is
don't you not a clue
oh yes i do it's a golden version of my
book the book i used to perform rituals
for lynetta hers looks way more ornate
than mine considering i ended reality
with mine i can't imagine how dangerous
hers must be wait a minute this guy that
suspicious man outside they all match
missy's book
and your clothes and your hair what's
going on here she making all this happen
oh god when i expected her to do
something crazy i thought she was just
going to show up with a hatchet or
something missy look
i'm sorry but players got to play i just
got wrapped up in something please don't
hurry
you're sorry
why are you acting so afraid of me no i
mean i'm not but whatever
could it be that you know what this book
is capable of
i know what these lips are capable of so
give me a smooch baby i know all too
well but i also know that these
incantations take at least five seconds
to pronounce and that's if she gets it
right on the first try so worst case i
have five seconds to stop her if i dash
for my ritual knife behind her i might
be able to kill her before those are
terrible to me that's a little
it's a little grotesque if i can
distract her i might be able to buy some
myself for more time
missy look baby i'll do
whatever you want anything
i can be rather
demanding i can be rather
supplying
that's the opposite of demand i learned
that in economics name your price
so bold
in that case i have three commands okay
number one you'll address me as your
highness from now on
so when i come home it's welcome home
your highness okay so
the second half of that request
i think has some other strings when she
comes home she wants to move in but that
means
whatever it's not like i'm gonna have to
actually fall through on these at least
one of us is about to die
as you wish your highness what else
number two
you'll quit your job so you can spend
every waking moment catering to me
you're one and only
okay
sure whatever just a little bit more
until i'm sprinting range of that knife
and number three uh-huh you'll obey
every order and whim i have absolutely
without question
oh indubitably your highness
um absolutely
[Music]
absolutely your highness
[Music]
i suppose if you will too whatever i ask
them there's no need to use any of these
dreadful spells on you no no need to
matter
i believe you can help me with them
here oh
she just handed over her book without a
second thought yellow energy pulses and
crackles from my fingertips she is she
not here to hurt me
confused
i've liked you for a long time and
you're a capable bookkeeper
handsome to boot
there's no reason we can't simply work
together i guess not after all a
relationship based on threats of
violence and fear is no good right well
i suppose you're right but i did have a
good time with lynetta
right
we narrowly escape with our lives just
now who's we
but something is bothering me how does
she remember that i stood her up in the
reality that ended under lynette's
awakening
and how did she get in through my window
i doubt she was able to climb several
stories dressed like that and then pass
through my locked window without
breaking it there's only one possible
answer
alright your highness i'm ready to enter
my lifetime of servitude to you i just
have one small request first
[Music]
could you tell me what this is
your worcestershire sauce
what about it
so you're an eldritch god disguised
doesn't he
how did you figure that out so suddenly
uh
isn't it obvious no human being can
pronounce
worse
of course not it's an eldridge alone
word
why else would it be spelled like that
ah yeah exactly exactly
after all this time i wasted trying to
seduce you in this slovenly form yeah
slovenly i was about to say
slovenly
yeah you should have tried using your
eldritch form instead i would have
fallen in love immediately
what but you think
cosmic entities
are attractive
as a human
i mean yeah did you see le
le
it's eldritch i can't speak it 3d women
are fine but 4th dimensional girls with
non-euclidean geometry are smoking hot
they've got curves i can literally get
lost in
if i had known that you're attracted to
my cosmic godhood i would have just led
with that well you didn't even need to i
could see it i could see it in your eyes
myself
i am esther
king in yellow
diamond
king
king air heiress king harris lovely to
meet you
she's gorgeous a bonafide eldritch king
in my room king oh man all my fantasies
of smooching and eldershore are coming
true an eldritch royalty to boot i'd
assume that a god would be above royalty
because what is but what is a god do a
king what does god do a king
the king in yellow sounds familiar i
can't remember why my memory of my other
existence is kind of fuzzy what i do
remember is that her followers tend to
be incredibly violent towards cult
disloyal to other gods
like lanetta [ __ ] i kind of got swept up
in the moment and almost forgot i
already pledged fealty to a different
god this reality or not
ah wait i'm sorry i'm already involved
with another god i'm following lynetta i
know so loyal so faithful and devoted
that's why i want you to be my follower
instead
well i guess those aren't mutually
exclusive if you don't understand
english language exchange for serving me
i shall grant you anything you desire
wealth
power
whatever that rotten witch lanetta
offered you
i can double it
well i mean
i got a smooch couldn't you give me
double of that
she promised me a smooch
you handed over your reality to her
for a singular smooch
are you mad well i mean we're talking
about other stuff here it was a good
smooch after all you heard me so you'll
match your offer then or double it
you'll double it i
suppose
if that's all you're selling the world
for then a smooch can be
arranged
i asked for double the smooch
no way you promised to double yes
sorry got excited that's two smooches
that's what you promised
are you a king or not two of them on the
lips
both of them twice
i
will be
i just usually my followers ask for
inordinate wealth unquestionable fame
and influence or some lavish indulgence
petty things compared to a smooch
nobody's ever dared to ask to kiss me
before so no none of us said anything
about kissing so
she's blushing for real you really want
to smooch me
absolutely
your terms are amenable
suffice it to say i'll expect you to
perform your scenes flawlessly in
exchange
what
scenes the prompt book i gave you
contains the script for the king in
yellow
oh you mean this spell book that i was
so afraid of it's just a damn play
this thing is just a playbook where are
all the power invoking rituals
is this some sort of peasant joke that
i'm too rich to understand
no
we aren't barbaric swamp folk casting
hocus pocus in a cave we have a little
class
to invoke my power my play must be
performed perfectly
this is amenable
perfectly i don't always get these
rituals i mean scenes right the first
time what happens if i botch my lines or
get a scene your performance will
receive a scathing review in the karkos
and times publication
and you'll also be killed
acceptable
i'm getting those smooches no matter
what
dearest
i'll break a smooch that didn't make
sense but happened
all right what do we got in this book
what is this all about uh host click and
drag the first word line slowly greeting
stranger
okay tis a party for which i below the
eye invite the king in yellow
so come all ye to jesus
where thy mast upon you to my masquerade
until he may come to lost
hope first there may be still king
okay what do we got here
uh-huh oh i can't read that
hello
okay
what are you doing over there
oh
you're
you look beautiful
i asked
whoa
don't
do that oh your highness sorry what all
i did was say hello speak my name
dearest
there's a reason i am she who is not to
be named
immortal saying esther summons me to
them
andy
if i can't say your name what am i
supposed to call you you have many
options you may call me your majesty
your grace my king
you could even call me your royal
highness if you're feeling particularly
subservient okay esther that's dress
dress
stop that
i'm glad that me and this guy are in the
same wavelength because i am him and he
is me anyway so i've got a book here
with pages and whatnot and i don't seem
to need any setting exterior in view of
the city
where'd you go
it's there mr
fine
is there anything what do i look like
right now
what's going on with me i've got a
smoochie on my forehead or is that a
mouth
i'm not sure what that is hey it's me
why are these red they weren't red
before
okay is there any other secret that i'm
not seeing here
[Applause]
hello you guys still out here
okay let's get a show on the road and
whatever esther
there you are
all right
greetings stranger fortune fellow it is
a party for which i bellow
oh outside
oh
oops
oops okay we're looking for
exterior in view city that's what it is
okay
all right greet you trader a fortune
fellow teacher party food shy below
[Music]
oh greeting stranger fortune fellow
where thy mass upon you to my masquerade
until he may come for lost you fill hope
for us there may be still
oh
streets darken to the curfew that must
hark and why so loudly does thou bark in
the dim city of util yeah okay thank you
detention quite unwholesome you'll
instill from the souls of pour your tail
why attract so much ill will
[Music]
but i don't know
uh
this one
that is just what i must seek see hidden
somewhere amongst the meekly tis one
invitee i seek he
shall all my mistakes undo
says the king in yellow whose great
wealth i shall accrue when his shadow
passes through wealth will come to i
and you
shall surely languish and this whole
town will know anguish for the king as
whom they say which shall this city
indeed smite
if he comes you're telling you and i
will know his might i'll be lost within
a night what reward is worth that price
[Music]
a smoochie smoochie on your lips give it
to me
all i can think of his hips
put my face betwixt your hips uh
whatever a little too much
probably too much
wearing this expensive clothing pardon
from my family's loathing lasting till
i'm decomposing all my friends whom
strife i've caused yes preparing for
this night their forgiveness is the
cause they shall all be proud because
i had brought the king to us
because
us
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i know
why thank you that was actually pretty
fun i haven't gotten to flex my acting
chops since i scored no stranger to the
stage i can tell
[Music]
yeah i was the theater kid my school did
macbeth
a virtuoso of the part are we if you
perform shakespeare then you must be an
actor of sufficient ability to survive
my play probably not but let's see where
were you
the leading man
i was tree number four i
wasn't aware that was a rule oh very
important very important very important
it's not you weren't even the leading
tree
no
don't worry i was actually macbeth i
thought you said you were a tree
acting oh
you are good
[Music]
yes
whoa hey what's happening to you don't
fret dearest something is simply passing
between my planet's light in your
bedroom a cloud perhaps you know the
proverb wherever the golden light of
carcosa shines the shadow of the
unspeakable one is cast it's a literal
rule oh i see you can only be wherever
the light of my planet
shines
planet star planets
i can't reach you at night when you're
not standing in natural light or if
anything obstructs your view of carcosa
huh
that explains why missy had a weird
daytime curfew she'd literally vanish
when the sun sets what a cinderella-like
curse that also explains how she got in
my room my window may have been locked
but the curtains were open allowing the
light in
so she can't get into my room if i close
my curtains i was quite enjoying my time
with you
i wanted to stay a little
parting is longer sweet sorrow
it may be some time until your sky
clears
until then i bet you would do
okay
a forehead kiss
even though i saw that already
wow
well looks like i have one hell of a cho
oh [ __ ] lynette hasn't been summoned yet
and esther is stuck outside for the
moment so i have a moment to collect my
thoughts between lynetta and esther who
do i want to smooch or maybe more
accurately who am i more afraid of do i
stay with lynetta or do i follow esther
this time around she is offering twice
as many smooches after all i need to
make my choice if i want to stay with
lynette i should focus on casting spells
from her book
if i want a smoochester then i should
open my window again when the clouds are
clear and use esther's book
and if i try going for both well walking
down the middle of the road is bound to
get me run over as long as they aren't
both in the room at the same time i
should be safe right oh man what am i
gonna do
either way i need to talk to lynetta she
might be an avatar of world-ending
calamity but she might be able to help
me get my head straight speaking of my
head why does my forehead feel kind of
sticky
it's because there's a smoochy smoo on
it and i need to wash it off before
lynetta sees
but what if she does
what could be so terrible
what could be so terrible
would she i'm actually kind of curious
what she would do she saw
all right i think i need the red light
yeah here we go nope necklace sorry
what purpose oh
it's me
hey lynette it's nice to see her despite
everything i've been through so far sure
she may have entered the reality i was
from but she never lied or to see me in
any way she told me up front what would
happen and i did it willingly that said
i'm really glad you're here but
can you tell me what happened to me to
that world really nothing about this
that reality fell to me
nothing there exists anymore like a
dream that ends oh so sad
just as i thought only
then why am i still here why did i
survive when the rest of that reality
didn't darling don't make me say it
it's embarrassing
you're still here
because
i'm i'm still dreaming about you
everything in existence is being dreamed
about by at least one eldritch god
so as long as you're on my mind
you'll exist somewhere oh
well that's actually kind of sweet in a
terrifying cosmic way
what would happen if every god stopped
dreaming at the same time what if you
woke up all at once
including all of the gods would cease to
be
hmm
okay and that can just happen at any
time don't worry
there's about 50 of us total so the
chances of all of us being awake at the
same time are low that's not bad
there's only like 50 of you and all
she probably knows esther very closely
kind of a big family huh a little bit
family do you know esther
darling i thought i told you not to
mention other women while we're together
especially not my sister
oh you don't have a great relationship
with her absolutely not we've been
fighting over planets and followers for
eons it wouldn't be a stretch to call us
nemesis
thanksgiving dinner must be awkward
what's that on your forehead
nothing
baby
my love darling pumpkin sugar
sweetie pie schnookums
uh squid face uh a tentacle
nice person
it looks like a lipstick mark
that's not from another god
is it darling
because if it is
well
you die here
no
the mailman
ritual paint ritual paint yep yes one of
the steps needed for your rituals
really yeah
which ritual
oh
you know
it's
a secret i'm going to pretend that this
lipstick mark came from a human
girlfriend
so that i can spare you
okay from now on if you contact another
god
i swear i'll stop being so sweet
[Music]
you wouldn't care if i had a human
girlfriend
why would i care about that
when it's a race against other gods to
amass as many followers as possible
expecting your followers to be celibate
is a bad move
for grammy roxanne it's actually a
requirement that you start a big family
or you get excommunicated from her
following oh
grandma roxanna i'm sure you've heard of
her she's got the most followers out of
any of us
she's the black goat of the woods
or the mother goddess of fertility okay
a fertility goddess you see i'll forgive
you to go to tuesday no funny ideas
mister
there's no telling what i'd do if you
cheated on me with a family member
[Music]
okay esther
looks like the clouds haven't cleared
yet i won't be able to see her right now
if i wanted to for now i should work
through lynette's spells again eldritch
hands saved my ass last time i better
cast that one in case i'm unable to talk
again she should listen to myself what
the hell is wrong with me man
okay i'm actually going to go back
that's all cool and all but i am kind of
curious of doing this without the
because ordinarily i would have done
that i don't think it matters it's just
like you get a little lore there okay so
i wash off
i'm gonna wash this [ __ ] off
okay
let's just close that up close that up
turn that off turn this off okay
oh is my necklace on yes it is
well i'm still in hot water whoa i've
actually gotten involved with her sister
messi affair is bad enough but with
another family member i'm toast if she
finds out esther looks like the cloud
okay she's clueless she hasn't clue
darling what's this i found under your
bed what is that what is that oh that's
my elders encyclopedia i haven't
translated yet but its diagrams are
useful you studied it extensively then
yes i sense i've made some sort of
mistake uh i guess why what's up darling
this is a dirty magazine
oh
really i thought it was an anatomical
guide big slippery shogoth girlfriends
vol 3.
i bet you can learn a lot of anatomy
from this
perv
well you know i said i haven't
translated it yet how was i supposed to
know the girl on the front isn't wearing
anything she's topless
uh-huh that's a girl just looks like an
amorphous mass of tentacles to me is
this what you wish i looked like
oh baby no
i really truly don't trust me look
lanetta you're s
broken hot i can never have eyes for
anyone else when i'm with you you're my
dream girl
sheesh
i seriously didn't know it was a dirty
mag it's okay
i forgive you okay
that said can i keep it a chance no
all right fine then okay perform
eldritch mouth
do i have any other what else is in here
never leave the lights off never leave
the lights off interesting
okay not much here nothing new anyway
all right well let's get the old hand
mouth okay
in the bathroom no amulet uh ritual
knife yes
we go in the
oh that's it we could just go in the
bathroom all right i'll be right back
baby
let's see let's do it
oh god
[ __ ] still as unnerving as i remember
that's all so different in this reality
this is just my hand now forever
it's such a nice day outside
it's a little dry for my liking but we
could totally have a date date
why don't you open your window little
light in here
oh
oh no
no wait what what is it
[Music]
uh you sure you want to do that what do
you mean
i mean uh don't you want to shower first
before you go out like last time huh
why would you suggest that because i'm a
pervert and i i wanna i wanna sneak a
peek oh no
don't tell me do i still smell like the
ocean
listen it's not that it's bad just a tad
salty heavens below i'm so sorry darling
i'll be right back
[Music]
no peeking you say
that was a close one if she opened that
window esther would have came i would
have been a goner
looks like the clouds have cleared and
lynette is out of the room if i want to
date esther it's go time otherwise i
want to stay with lanetta i need to make
absolutely sure that window never opens
ever
it's time to choose from this point on
my actions will have consequences
like this one
god damn it
still was still worth
i love it of course it's worth it all
right hang on
okay my actions have consequences you
say
really
well i like walking the middle path
okay backstage in closed room with a
mirror prepare
hmm
that's gonna be a little difficult if
she's in there
okay masquerade mask you got it i think
it said it was something about a ritual
knife
elegant robes you got it elegant robes
you got it ritual knife okay
all right
look in mirror to check if costume is
properly affixed
all right
looks like everything's in place except
for the blood dripping down my face i
feel all gussied up even for me this
outfit's pretty loud but even so the
beauty of this whole ensemble is out of
this world if lynette is showering in
here i better meet with esther in the
other room
all i have to do is stand where the
planet's light can reach me and
i already know what you're going to say
your highness yellow is more your color
than mine but i still look good
the window's not open but whatever you'd
be presentable before my royal court in
that
it's pretty snug fit the mask almost
feels alive like it's molding to fit my
face perfectly quite the opposite
dearest your face is molding to fit the
mask oh
that's good then i feel a twist of metal
digging into my temples it stuck to my
face somehow ow wow it really won't come
off
i may have failed to mention that we
re-enact the play with deadly accuracy
okay
your character never removes his mask
so neither shall you there surely should
it be a problem for someone who was
planning to be my eternal servant
correct
oh
no i can't even blink anymore my eyelids
are stretched to meet the
[Music]
cool
this is
what if i have to wear this to work when
i see my family when i see lanetta wait
a minute those strange people outside
they all had mass stuck to them too are
they past followers who became esther's
servants is that going to be my fate at
least i'll get some smoochies
[Music]
interior well lit okay well lit you got
it well lit indeed
welcome company
[Music]
oh
welcome company much cherished may my
loneliness thus perish through this
evening we shall share which would be
wasted by myself
no attendants have arrived tonight alas
besides thyself but i'll be beside
myself when the king when the the king
reveals himself
oh lay thine hands upon my bodice for
before you stand a goddess no this guest
of goldenrod is merely the first of the
night let us drink to your great wealth
and family and life lasting till your
afterlife all be yours once he arrives
[Music]
yes until my schemes may flourish we
shall haunt my empty empty fortress let
us dance a whirling dervish while we
feed our appetites by the morrow we
shall know if the king came tonight
midnight marks the final chime until
that comes
there is still time maybe graciously
obesity demonstrate a courtly patience
he declines no invitation he receives
upon his court
will know without report the king
arrived by your escort a prophecy of
grim import sure i don't like the people
outside the window
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you very much
thank you thank you
thank you
an immaculate performance dearest
there's only one more scene to reenact
and then this world will be mine
i probably should have asked before we
got to the final act but this play isn't
a tragedy no it's not
the ending is actually quite hilarious
oh good
oh that's actually a huge relief what
is slain and all of his wishes come true
in an unexpected way
in his ambitions of greed influence and
fame he dies penniless alone and
infamous okay
wait my character dies i'm gonna die i
thought you said it was a comedy is
merely tragedy from far enough away
i don't know if that's true
is she implying that she thinks my death
would be funny i get that she's an outer
god so human morals don't really apply
to her but that's gotta be cruel even
for her no way can i go through with
that sorry i don't want to die i don't
want to die again anticipated that you
might get cold feet after learning of
your character's fate however
my wrath is terror far beyond a touch of
stage fright
no for your sake dearest
do the [ __ ] scene
a little much
so what if i now do okay let's say for
now
uh
performing this ritual after esther's
mass grade will have consequences if you
see or hear something strange it's not
your imagination be ready proceed in
total darkness
okay
so i did
the masquerade that's what i just did
right
i just did the masquerade yes
maybe we just did the masquerade yes
the next one's the banquet okay i gotta
do the other one all right uh goodbye
later nerd later get out of here later
nerd okay um if you see or hear
something strange it's not your
imagination uh
total darkness no light no candles
ensure their images appear no way i
don't know what that means but okay
what if i put this on over that is that
gonna work it might work it might work
it might work
it might just work good thing that's a
long shower i put it on over the thing
wash face
oh that's no better
that's no better toll
that's no better at all
wear a mask or headpiece to distort your
features have a ceremonial knife on your
person always remembers the second step
on the page
the second step of the page is ensure oh
yeah
okay
here we go i'm going for gold
pink rather oh i can't get the ritual
mass to stay on over my masquerade one
i'm here what hello she's finished with
her shower
uh yeah i'm just working on my
pronunciation
she's right in front of me maybe if i
bury my face in this book she won't
notice the mask is fused to my face oh
are you stuck on a word i can help you
sound it out
let me see the page
no no no no i got it i'm a big boy
alien can't be harder to figure out in
english would probably be easier to read
if the book wasn't upside down darling
oh
that explains why i couldn't read it now
okay i think i've got it now darling why
are you holding it so close to your face
the font shouldn't be that small
uh my eyesight has been going for a
while now i gotta pick up some
prescription reading glasses so that i
keep putting it off and you know i don't
know you need glasses
i uh usually wear contacts but you
aren't wearing them now
oh guess what i must have drop them on
the ground uh somewhere in the last
reality darling yes my love
no
now oh okay
that's it i'm screwed if she sees this
masquerade mascot on my face you'll know
i've been meeting with esther
think think
hey ow
quick to the bathroom
oh no
will that door hold no telling if this
mask is still on my face when she gets
in
so i have no other option i dig my
fingers under the edge of the mask
that feels like i'm pulling my very
fingernails off for mere millimeters of
leverage the mask feels fused to my skin
i'm taking off large chunks of flesh
with every pull
this pain it's unreal what's going on in
there
i was do or die oh i take a deep breath
and pull the mass forward until my skin
is taut and there's no more give
than i
why did you lock me out darling
heavens below what happened to you
i
i can't even formulate thoughts right
now whatever happens here happens is
that why you were hiding your face
no baby oh my god
so shallow that i'd fuss over what you
look like
i'm here because i like you
no matter what happens to you
so don't be so self-conscious around me
okay oh that's really sweet but holy
[ __ ]
lynette
just let me hold you it's oh so sweet
and tender but
she's too sweet this feeling right now
almost makes tearing off my face worth
it
almost just stay right there
until you're mentally prepared to
continue
i need to be here for a few hours uh
okay
i end up blacking out from the pain
waking up sometime later in my bed the
golden mask was nowhere to be found
thanks oh
uh
maybe i should have done the other one
first uh
yeah whatever too late now
what
[Music]
oh that's probably not right that's
probably not right
oh this is not right oh
boy
yo boy yo boy
okay um okay well she's not there right
now
[Music]
and the heart is broken but i'd say that
heart that was very sweet oh god no
well i guess that's not happening
eldritch embrace very spooky don't worry
about these steps all you have to
lynetta yes darling yeah
i'm just checking but
you haven't tampered with my book right
what do you mean huh
this eldritch's embrace spell it looks a
bit different from the other rituals
how strange
what's the use you caught me it's not a
real ritual
i just i see how hard you're pushing
yourself to make it through these spells
for my sake
i thought maybe you could use a break
from the real rituals
so i could spoil you a little
oh
that's actually pretty sweet of you
there's no time for me even a quick one
i can't lose sight of my singular goal
smooching yet all right
i'll leave you to it then
you're leaving there's something i need
to check on it's probably nothing but
you haven't seen anything strange lately
have you i can't see anything at all i
don't have eyes anymore apparently i've
seen plenty of strange things lately
about her gods hands with mouths i meant
things beyond the usual strangeness
you haven't noticed anything
watching you have you
huh
hmm
sorry i guess i'm being the strange one
huh i'll just be right back
stay safe okay okay you got it thank you
thank you very much uh oh
so sweet
that's so sweet performing this ritual
after esther's banquet will have
consequences
okay what does it say about the other
one though that's the question right
uh there's nothing oh whoa
blackfyre reveals secrets interesting
[Music]
hey
well no i've i've gotten one more than
that but whatever that's fine it
probably just didn't count it uh for now
but i definitely have it i know i do
i know i definitely do but is there
another one here
nothing is just your imagination okay
should i do
well actually wait no i needed to see if
this one says anything
masquerade banquet is next banquet
do not make a mistake or a hungry
uninvited guest may arrive in blue
that sounds like a secret to me
ingredients from cold storage okay what
if i make
the black candles
huh
okay no ingredients
could i get them
yes ow
it's fine it's fine allow
and then
i'm gonna make i'm gonna do this chant
but it's black candles
the room is filled with the
mouth-watering aroma of perfectly
seasoned meat and fresh fruit
there must be a magical component
involved here because i see no less than
three of my favorite dishes esther is
strutting towards my bed surely you
don't intend to merely watch me eat
dearest why are you strutting towards my
bed
i didn't think she was gonna let me have
any
don't mind if i
[Music]
this feast don't feed it to me that's
less exciting
it's not like groans of murders anger
from outside the door was that from the
mass stalkers outside if they've all got
mass on their faces they must be
hester's followers or even ex-partners
then the groans were of jealousy makes
sense they've been locked outside all
this time i bet they'd kill for the
chance of spending any time with esther
just a moment dearest what is the thread
count of your silken sheets at least one
thousand i presume
silk my blankets are cotton
perhaps i'll just stand while you feed
me instead
so picky if she's that ugly maybe i'll
start with the grapes something that'll
feed her princess complex
oh
yeah okay i'm glad
i think i can have one of these dream on
my lips have already touched it if you
want an indirect kiss you'll have to be
more clever than that okay oh yes you
wound anything eat anything my lips have
touched either it's not
you were eyeing this cream puff right
would you like me to feed you a bite oh
heavens fellow yes
i am pleased by this new attitude of
yours here i'm gonna eat it first i
casually take a bite out of the cream
puff what do you think you're doing
eating delicious it's so good never had
anything like it let me try um oh you
wanna bite even though my lips have
touched it
i
i don't want it after all uh-huh well if
you don't want it then i guess i can
have some now right
it's really delicious nothing tastes
better than food with a twist of
eldritch magics it's a shame you don't
want any of it
what's it gonna be watch me eat your
favorite dessert or suffer an indirect
gift
[Music]
what was that i order you to hand over
the cream puff
very well my king
ah for over the other half of the cream
puff to her eager hands but instead
oh
i forgot i was hand feeding her
her lips are insanely soft against my
fingers
she's damn cute when she drops her
sadistic front i do more but i feel
those husks staring jealous daggers into
my back they'll tear my head off if i
let this go on shouldn't we save some of
this for the play it'll hurt the
performance if we eat the entire set
won't it
very well
but i i thought it was saying something
about like do not make a mistake or an
uninvited hungry uninvited guest make
arrive but i did
they're on the blue fire
i'm kind of curious about that hang on
let me let me real quick let me go back
a little bit okay let me try it with the
lights uh
just that easy
hmm that would be all of the secrets
then right i think so
some of the shopping shops
okay what are we doing what are we doing
here okay so that's you
uh i need to do the
[Music]
what the hell was i hearing
that is there
okay
so technically i've done the banquet
haven't i
so now this
well lit okay
no roves
no necklace offering is on my person
hello i've already used up my supplies
to cook for esther all that's left is
leftovers from her banquet oops no good
darling
[Music]
it's no good to leave dirty dishes out
especially after eating so much
you know
it's important to take your diet
seriously you should be more careful
when your health is on the line okay
[Music]
i'll remember that this much food
it's surprising that you were able to
eat it alone
uh-huh yeah well i know i don't look it
but i'm a big eater especially with
sweets you're so interesting darling
i'm learning something new about you
every day uh-huh
i can't tell if she's onto me or if
she's in denial but i sense i'm in
trouble it just can't be helped if
you've got a sweet tooth do you want me
to feed you the last of it
what the leftovers uh i'm good it's no
good to waste food darling oh no
no you were right i should wash my diet
more carefully if you've already eaten
the poison you may as well lick the
plate as they say again i've i've never
heard that before uh with our first day
but i'm full make room in your dessert
stomach
she's merciless
no
you don't want to eat i wonder
if this isn't the food that you like
it sounds like you're saying this was
for someone else oh you know but that
can't be right
after all my darling wouldn't secretly
be hosting communion with other gods
behind my back
right
darling
yep you right those are dangerous eyes i
don't know kind of cute i've got my back
against the wall here
even if she knows i have to keep up
appearances here or she'll drag me into
oblivion without a second thought i
reluctantly unclenched my teeth and
opened my mouth
a juice soaked morsel from the leftovers
as shoveled into my mouth it feels
gritty with an unusual texture like it's
covered in thousands of small hairs it
tastes strangely i can't even begin to
guess what food this used to be i try to
gulp it down before i can taste it but
it's too big to swallow a hole
if i just bite it in half and swallow
the pieces i might get it down before i
gag as i bite down it bursts like a
tomato filling my mouth with a sweet
juice it tastes extremely fruity sort of
pineappley even
that is
that is good
better than good it's great
god like nectar instantly addictive
ambrosia more i need more it's too
delicious to have just one bite
it's seriously like nothing else as soon
as i swallow i feel the immediate
effects of withdrawal
my fond memories of any other food fade
daughter disgust the mere thought of
eating again makes my stomach churn
greedily i take another bite filling my
mouth with as much as i can take the
smooth nectar bursting from every bite
swims around in my mouth coating every
surface it's so delicious that's making
my mouth tingle huh did i just bite my
cheek why do i taste blood
the dull tingling suddenly turns into a
sharp sting then a new unbearable
burning my whole mouth feels raw like
i'm gargling acid it's like my mouth is
being digested i lurch to spit it out
but my willpower fails me i just can't
bear to spit it out it's too good
just a little while longer let me do it
just a little while
longer oh my god the food falls out of
my mouth with a splat is a heap of
bloody viscera
it might be imagination but i swear i
spat out twice as much as i put in my
mouth
the horror good boy
you know how much i love to spoil you
do you remember the last time we did
this when you couldn't speak back to me
no
i do remember so you know what happens
next
right
one last ritual and then we say goodbye
again
as always take as much time as you need
i'll wait as long as it takes darling
okay
who knew waking up could be so
exhausting
uh-huh can i take a nap before you uh
you know me so well
but don't try anything while i'm
sleeping this time
i know what you did
don't look so surprised
right before our date would have ended
you betrayed me
don't think that there aren't
consequences between realities darling
i've already dealt with that pesky
breakup spell on your book as i'm sure
you've noticed so just take the straight
narrow path of loyalty in front of you
and we can keep doing this forever
and ever and ever
and ever
could you get the lights from me again
darling
of course
of course uh oh
interesting they're inverted but i don't
know why
interesting i better get my smooch
that's all i gotta say i better get my
smooch okay so i got a dilemma right
i don't think i've been doing this right
but i'm gonna go with what i've been
doing before no light beside open window
that helps because
sleeping anything else i need
robes and mask uh
ooh
about that um
well it seems to be on my face so
whatever i guess it's okay
rob's a mask and that's it okay
this is probably fine this is probably
fine this is probably fine
oh god oh my god what happened
what did what did i do what did i what
did i do what did i do oh i didn't i
don't think i had the window open okay
whatever let's let's just
okay
oh but it's gonna do one and not the
other i don't know what it's gonna do
oh god
oh god oh this is not right oh this is
not right oh this is not right
oh oh that's not right oh god what is
happening
i don't know
hang on hold on
hold on wait hold on hold on i
wait no no
no
okay let me just let me make sure i've
actually got this right i'm gonna go
back here
and then i'm just gonna speed through
this because i know okay elegant rolls
this is exactly what i meant to do bam
boom
ritual knife i have it
bam no bam no
look in the mirror complete got it okay
okay easy enough
yeah yeah yeah that that that okay this
right this right okay broken heart
that's fine right and then i look at
this i see that the pages are weird
there we go got that okay switchy over
okay banquet do red fire
bam
got it switch
no robes no necklace
offering
got it
she's pissed she feeds me brosie
she's sleepy now
that's fine okay
okay this is i think i didn't open the
window robes and mask
robes
i don't know if i have the mask but
whatever
oh yeah ain't good
let's see what happens
damn the night and mournful sco
tomorrow's scornful wicked morning
unremorseful why tonight must i be
mournful for ambitions unfulfilled after
all my preparations all the daylights i
have killed
why is it us only still oh
why are my wishes
your actions unfulfilled permitted this
result truly befitted to a hunger such
as thine no your greed is grave and tomb
encrypt in which you die it's within
your grace you fried dearest host the
end is nigh
wretched guest you've come to mock me
for amusement thou was talking and so in
the town you stalk me to watch my
schemes fall apart strip thy mask
apologize then hastily depart leave thee
just my broken heart leave not else in
hole or pot i wear no mask now witness
for it was thee who has to permit this
golden yes to own the dimness of the
city of util
[Music]
shadow's on uh-huh tail and whose shadow
you're in still dark as death is now
util
[Music]
draw thy blade from mind contusion my
life reaches its conclusion cruelty
matched by your delusion that you truly
are the king
yes you would have granted all my wishes
not forsaken me if indeed you were the
king
why would you have murdered me
granted all your wishes i'm afraid i
disagree all alone you are with all of
your remaining family
and as vision turns to darkness you have
claimed to all you see and you'll wear
that mask and robe for the rest of all
your life indeed and the strong will
fall to illness haunt your tail with
stillness and none left alive to witness
my ascension to your tail and from the
catacombs shall spill the cries of
innocence laid still we heard from lady
and from smithy and from throne to
peasant mill cries unprecedented in the
history of util
wales unlike they'll ever be again in
dark util
that's your invitations quill
[Music]
okay am i dead now did i die
thank you
oh thank you
you're all too kind no one's clapping
listen to that applause dearest
oh this recitation uh-huh innumerable
voices make up the cacophony of cheering
outside my door fanatical revelry
screams of terror and sadistic amusement
all amidst thunderous applause the king
is coming miles dearest smiles
aren't you proud of yourself yes why why
didn't you use a stage knife i'm really
bleeding out here my blood streams from
a gaping wound in my chest my abdomen is
unseen to ensure you stay in character
call it method acting if you will okay
oh with sweet sorrow the curtain falls
and the show begins the stage is now set
for you to inscribe the yellow sign do
this and i will bestow upon you the
smooch i promised
you mean the smooches you promised
plural you said you'd get me too even
now that's really all you can think
about yep well i'm dying so might as
well get it the world is about to be
enslaved by a horror from beyond the
stars you're dying from a stab wound
and you're worried about smooches
yeah you are
an interesting human
it is a pity that you'll soon cast away
your individuality for me yeah not
really worth it
i'm more of a latany guy if i'm being
perfectly honest uh so you know because
of that
because of that you know the whole uh
final yellow sign what is that about
your sign is only visible with drawable
by those who've witnessed or performed
the king in yellow play being exposed to
the yellow sign after witnessing or
performing the play the king in yellow
will cause a permanent irreversible
obsession with the king or court and
carcosa this is obscene objection
persists after death
if you are content to spend the rest of
your life with the king dim all lights
leaving your window open and light black
fire candles this will allow
otherworldly images to reveal themselves
draw the shape below without the x
yeah well you know
not really about that i'm really about
uh latin lanetta lynette why do i keep
thinking latony is not right
am i dying
sure looks like i'm dying
that's better
that's better
better better better uh ritual knife uh
sure let's try this one
[Music]
i mean i'm already bleeding out so i
guess it uh
it's all the same really
[Music]
wait stop
lynette takes the book from my hands we
need to talk uh-oh i
i wanted to apologize for being
so nasty to you earlier
truth is
even though i knew you were acting
strangely
i was still clinging to you selfishly
because i was so so mad at you
i just
wanted to have the best groundwork for a
happy future together
so i thought i could scare you straight
now i know that's not possible
not here not now
you're just not the same person that
ended reality for me so long ago oh babe
so
let's break up oh
no
lanetta i'm sorry
there's no need to end this reality just
so we can have an unhealthy failing
relationship
so
i'll go back to sleep
before billions die for my sake oh come
on
but where do we go from here what's left
after today tomorrow
silly
[Music]
you're taking the book with you too i'm
just giving it back to mo
it's not like i'll have a need for it
hopefully this book never finds its way
back to your world
for your sake
and mine oh come on handle the book but
if you survive
could you throw out the rest of these
summoning artifacts it's no good to keep
things that remind you of me you know
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm sorry it's a beautiful day outside
you should open the window
maybe let in some light i heard a
goodbyes maybe there's still a chance
for us
in reality far from this one
but the best i can do in this one
is spare you
you're not going to kill me no i am
going to kill you to spare you from the
slow agonizing end
i'm sparing you the pain of being alive
when the fog lifts and reality sets in
oh okay you won't have to live to see
the consequences of the spells you've
already completed right right of course
there is that way
you won't feel a thing okay
it was fun
okay
[Music]
till we meet again
oh but look i got a smile
tentacle stains on my face okay so
clearly there's a lot of different
things to do here there's just ton and i
did not do it right
so
i'm going to do a different methodology
there's there's obviously so many
different ways you could do just like
straight one side straight another i
think
what what's obvious is you have this one
where if you perform it after the
masquerade it'll have consequences but
there's nothing in this other one that
says
if you perform it after there's
consequences it doesn't say that at all
actually so let me go ahead and just do
this one um if you see or hear something
strange it's not your imagination be
ready interesting okay total darkness no
candles whatever got it wear a mask or
headpiece to distort your features
what if i wear the mask here
that way it wouldn't be weird if i had
it later you know what i mean
okay
okay hello handsome my mouth i can't
move it again just like last time okay
calm down focus if i can control my hand
then
hey hey
oh you're learning oh sorry you're
learning to control your allergy smell
so soon i'm getting the hang of it
seems i still have my muscle memory from
the last reality good oh try saying
something
you must have been studying huh
yeah i'm pretty fluent now right
oh what
volting would be a dangling participle
error since you started the sentence
with the yaw instead of yaya
and since you and i are intimate you
don't need the gin suffix
no need to be so formal with your
girlfriend
uh
i guess i still have a lot of learning
to do
yeah
uh how do you
damn it it's actually really difficult
to speak english through my hand
aurelian rolls off the tongue
embarrassing hand tongue that is
how do you speak human lang language so
actually most of us are hyper polyglots
you can't get people to worship you if
you can't communicate with them hmm
really what else do you know english
mandarin spanish french arabic asl
parcel tongue elvish undercommon swedish
hey you made some of those up all
languages are made up darling that's a
good point
okay well okay that's good okay so i did
that
now she's right there which is a bit of
an issue
oh this will get her out right
right
ah
babe
okay i've seen this before yadda yadda
okay
good now i can do this other one
with no consequences because that's a
good heart there that's good that's good
take this one all right and then check
my features elegant robes i think i'm
wearing them no i'm not
i was just didn't seem like i was let's
try this
oh mass won't stay on my face it just
keeps slipping off oh god
hi yeah you would never lie to her
correct huh wouldn't dream of it then
tell me
what happened to your face uh
i try to avert my gaze but her iron
grass holds my chin firmly in place her
long sharp nails dig into my cheek
unfortunate accident
and an even more unfortunate phase for
now we shall conceal that hideous visage
of yours beneath the hood of your robe
hopefully and in the interest of not
having further accidents
you will have my undivided attention
from now on you may express your
gratitude to your king
uh-huh thank you your highest
one more thing i may not be as barbaric
as my sister
but i assure you i can be twice as
dreadful
do not give me cause to demonstrate okay
okay well that's a broken heart okay
there's got to be a way to get them
on my side let me speed through this i'm
going to get the various versions of
this because otherwise i'm going to be
here forever let me speed through this
and then i'm going to
you know you know
you know what i'm gonna do okay i'll be
back
okay
just as perfect as last time but lee
[Music]
easy okay
she's sleeping and that's fine
she's happy and that's good
now who's not going to be happy is this
lady
red fire candles uh-huh
wait i can explain
i have nothing
she's on to me well there's leadnetta
sleeping in the bed right there so just
go hungry i get breakfast this morning
okay this is the same this is the same
oh god no i'm glad i'm skipping this no
no no no this is what you were about to
try to feed me
then this will be your trough swine
oh it's the same thing it's
it's ambrosie like okay
gross
okay well that was good
uh goodbye if i do the other path
dying anyway
then i wouldn't see it to the end ah
this is confusing i just noticed the
tentacles down here i've never noticed
this before
uh
i guess if i do
would it mean anything else rogues and
masks
[Music]
okay so now there's that and then i do
this and then i have the knife so all i
gotta do is this five times
okay
stop i
need to talk to you first oh yeah what
oh what is it what if what if what if we
didn't complete the final ritual uh what
if i stayed to sleep longer so we could
have a little more time together uh just
you
and me
lingering in a doomed world alone
like an endless dream come true
there is that doesn't that sound nice
that does sound nice it does sound nice
[Music]
wait no oh we were finally going to be
together forever
we would have been so happy oh
this reality is doomed you said it once
the dream has to end eventually if you
keep a dream going on forever it has to
become a nightmare eventually or worse
it becomes reality
take a look at the world around us and
take a good look at me is this what you
want a reality to be like
of course not
but my dream of being with you forever
[Music]
can never come true
but we can be together for a short time
forever but
i'm not ready to say goodbye again
why can't we just stay for good mm-hmm
together only be big meetings
i don't know if we're saying goodbye
forever i don't know if i'm your dream
guy then there's no way this is goodbye
forever it's no big deal you can always
dream of me again
please don't go
i can stay asleep a little longer i
can't
be right back
[Music]
thank you
for giving me a dream wonderful enough
to remember clearly
[Music]
[Laughter]
awaken to oh
i oh ain't that sweet ain't that sweet
okay but that's still only two of six my
god so if i'm at act three performed
what does that mean what does it say as
far as like oh
so that's two stars interesting and this
has nothing
i should be pissed
all right so if i did act three just now
then what if i just go ahead and do this
with here
dim all lights open window blackfire
right okay blackfire all lights are off
right
i am entropy
disorder
where things are built tall i appear to
knock them down okay
monuments
nations relationships
some of these husks have wedding rings
on their fingers i steal the hearts and
minds of the rich or powerful to break
them and litter my court with them like
gold dust
but why me for people i'm broke because
i am the breeze of chaos that knocks
down any tower that challenges the
grandness of my court hmm your
relationship with my sister was one of
those things okay before i only pursued
you because you have a great deal of
cloud amongst the knight going crowd and
shrewd wealthy types okay you would have
been an incredibly powerful servant who
would have been able to draw in
countless wayward souls that meet my
standards at least
until that reality ended and you undid
all of my hard work yeah all of my
followers that i had stolen from lametta
and i had no choice but to abandon that
reality fair there's nothing left to
destroy if nothing exists you see
but in this reality
i've stolen away her most powerful asset
you
just as i've stolen every member of my
entourage
all the husks they're bleeding from
their chests onto their elegant robes
just like me
all these people why why
because it's what i do mm-hmm yeah
no i mean why are they still here are
they kind of third wheeling our moment
here check them out huh
i don't feel any different you're
supposed to be obsessed with me
ah i already was since i first saw you
that's why your little spell didn't work
you can try and resist it all you want
but one way or another you're my eternal
slave from now on
are you proposing to me i accept dearest
i'm not talking about marriage what i'm
talking about is catering to my every
whim
anticipating my every desire
and living solely
to please me
[Music]
yeah uh that just sounds like
i'm talking about marriage servitude
where you do nothing but kiss the ground
i walk on and revere me for all of time
smooch servitude unlike anything on
earth where you never so much as think
of anyone else smooch
no we have that on earth and it's called
marriage it's different
it's not it's true it is not how so
freedom forever you are only permitted
to do as i say
yep and it means preparing every single
one of my meals for me whenever i still
wish
uh yeah for sure
it means never being allowed to quit
your servitude you'll never be free of
me so long as you live
until death do us party then exactly
yeah okay i'm sorry but you're literally
just describing being married i mean hey
if that's what you want then i'm in
let's get married
oh reward
[Music]
i got him you shouldn't i
i
i stole you away
i ruined your relationship with lynetta
uh i preferred you from the beginning
spoiler alert i didn't i already broke
up with lynette in the other reality
actually why are you being so persistent
you can't really want to marry me that
badly you're just trying to act all
smooth so i give you your second smooth
yes
save it for our wedding day
you can't be serious
right
[Music]
all the way to the honeymoon oh my god i
like the little bandage on the chest
that's cute okay so this is now three of
six i'm still not at the end here
shockingly
uh
so what we need to do is all right let's
uh i'm assuming actually this is going
to give me two hearts which is good and
then i can do the bad for the other one
and then i can accept that bad and
there's gotta be one where it's a combo
right okay whatever whatever whatever
whatever whatever whatever whatever
okay and now this should be
you've met of the terrible end haven't
you oh god
i guess we have
all right good
yep that's great
all right whatever there's two
other ends here there's two other ends
so there's some way to get both of them
to be happy with you i know that there's
gotta be a way i don't know how it's a
way but it's definitely a way i don't
have time however in this episode to
take care of it because i've already
recorded for almost two hours with this
one so i'm gonna end this one here i
will move on to chapter three after it
and then i will come back
and finish that one because i want to
continue the story instead of just
fumbling around trying to find things so
i love this this is fantastic thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below next episode will be
coming real soon thank you and as always
i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you